et bien justement on va continuer à
parler de la Constitution puisque
aujourd'hui cet après-midi le Conseil
constitutionnel va rendre son avis sur
la loi immigration il pourrait censurer
certaines mesures qui ont été ajoutées
au texte par les républicains comme le
durcissement de l'accès aux aides social
pour les étrangers durcissement
durcissement de l'accès également au
regroupement familial si vos mesures
sont censurées ce sera un échec pour
lesr ce sera un échec pour les Français
déjà parce que les Français plébiscitent
largement les mesur ure de la loi
immigration qui a été votée grâce aux
apports de la droite et on verra ce que
dit le Conseil constitutionnel mais nous
nous contestons le fait que des mesures
ne soient pas constitutionnelles qu'il y
ait des cavaliers législatif quasiment
toutes les mesures sur lesquelles c'estd
des mesures hors sujet par rapport au
texte voilà un cavalier législatif c'est
un une disposition qui est sans rapport
avec le texte toutes les mesures que
nous avons fait adopter ont une relation
avec la question de l'immigration et de
l'intégration qu'il s'agisse du délit de
séjour irrégulier qu'il s'agisse du
durcissement des conditions d'accès à la
nationalité qu'il s'agisse du titre de
séjour étranger malade qu'il s'agisse de
l'absence d'automaticité d'acquisition
de la nationalité française pour les
jeunes qui devront en faire la demande
donc toutes ces mesures elles ont un
rapport et plus encore
elles ont
été adoptées dans le pass
dans le passé elles ont été jugées
constitutionnell la gauche les a retiré
du droit par exemple le délit de séjour
irrégulier il a été jugé conforme à la
Constitution en 2011 ça c'est le mémoire
que vous avez déposé auprès de du
Conseil constitutionnel av déposé un
mémoire auprès du Conseil
constitutionnel un mémoire très précis
pour dire de notre point de vue ces
mesures ne sont pas
antionstitutionnelles et puis sur les
dépenses les les prestations sociales
non contributives en droit au
aujourd'hui il existe une disposition
qui fait que le RSA ne peut pas être
accordé à quelqu'un ou sur le minimum
retraite aussi a sur le minimum retraite
qui n'a pas fait état d'une d'un séjour
régulier en France depuis 5 ans ça
existe déjà dans le droit ça existe mais
en effet il y a une menace sur 30 à 40
articles du du du projet de loi qui
pourrait faire l'objet d'une censure
d'une censure partielle ou bien d'êt
considéré comme des des des cavaliers
législatifs est-ce que s'il y avait une
une partie des articles qui n'étaient
pas retenus par le Conseil
constitutionnel il y aurait pas un
problème de crédibilité politique
vis-à-vis de de vous étant donné que
vous avez manifestement défendu des
articles qui étaient antionstitutionnels
alors moi je voudrais dire que ça c'est
le discours de la majorité ça c'est le
discours de la majorité qui dit voyez
ils sont pas sérieux ils ont fait voter
ils nous ont obligé à adopter des
mesures dont ils savaient qu'elles
n'étaient pas constitutionnelle
d'ailleurs le gouvernement attend la
censure de ces mesures donc ça montre
bien le double discours de la majorité
sur sur ce sujet je viens de de de de
vous expliquer pourquoi toutes les
mesures que dont le gouvernement espère
qu'ell soit retoqué ont été en son temps
adopté et validé par le Conseil
constitutionneles été constitutionnel et
aujourd'hui elle ne le serait plus donc
ça c'est quand même un problème mais
surtout le grand perdant dans cette
affaire ce ne serait pas la droite le
grand gagnant ne serait pas la majorité
les perdants ce seraient les Français ça
veut dire que définitivement la France
ne peut pas recouvrer sa souveraineté en
matière migratoire ça c'est extrêmement
grave et pour ça veut dire très
concrètement madameevard que si sil y a
une censure partielle encore une fois du
du texte est-ce que vous relancerez le
débat sur un une modification de la
Constitution bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr
bien sûr mais vous n'avez pas de
majorité pour voter cette réforme de la
Constitution c'est un veux pieux vous
n'avez absolument pas les moyens de
porter cette réforme de la Constitution
je pense pense très clairement que alors
d'abord la situation à l'Assemblée au
Sénat n'est pas la même est-ce qu'au
Sénat il peut y avoir des avancées en
matière de révision de la Constitution
sur ces questions c'est à discuter euh
moi ce que je voudrais dire c'est que à
force d'ignorer le sentiment des
Français les Français disent dans toutes
les enquêtes d'opinion qu'il faut
absolument que la France retrouve la
maîtrise en matière d'immigration soit
la majorité choisit de dire très bien le
Conseil constitutionnel a censuré on est
tranquille la droite a échoué nous
finalement notre double langage à payer
et puis qu'importe l'opinion des
Français ça ça un prix c'est un coût et
en 2027 on verra le le coût politique de
ce renoncement et de cette lâcheté soit
courageusement on dit il y a un problème
le cadre constitutionnel actuel ne le ne
permet pas de le
et on se met autour de la table et on
réfléchit à la façon de de faire bouger
les lignes en la
matière